spring in Doug Gottlieb Fox Sports
former college basketball player and
college basketball analyst for Fox
Sports what do you make of the press
conference with Sean Miller yesterday
hold on did you really screw up the read
for your own universe yes I did Doug
that really happened yes well you know
what you do is I threw the read to let
people know that I'm human and that you
make mistakes in this business and then
you try to get better and that's my
first mistake in this business yeah I
see a first ascent well Gus is great and
sage and all everybody else I'm hurt
that you didn't ask me to teach a class
on what not to say I am a little too
late with that Doug but there's a grad
school but all was oh I look away is I
guess classic oh does it take right and
that I think you know look we both
worked at ESPN I think we both really
enjoyed our time there I like marks
labor but there's obviously some errors
in that reporting even if they got the
gist of part of the story right because
they say they changed the timeline that
went back in put the timeline back to
where it originally was and maybe they
it would appear I mean look Sean was
pretty steadfast that it had nothing to
do with DeAndre hatin which leads you to
believe that there's another player I
think many of us know who that other
player probably is another player that's
involved in somebody trying to get money
for him so like the only thing left to
do is to go to the tape right this isn't
it is right now it's all hearsay he said
he said but eventually the wiretap will
at least appear in KITT he played in
court and then will be you know public
and then once it's public will know what
is it so I think you know the the
University Arizona they've responded and
supported him and Ben Alonzo Trier was
also reinstated last yesterday so
they're going all-in yeah but I you know
it's still a tepid response because at
the end of their statement it says for
now so we'll see
do you believe Sean Miller I want to I
want to and and and that's not
convincing can't no no I mean look but
how many people that we believe in have
lied to us
right like how many people went to the
mattresses over Lance Armstrong or
Rafael Palmero
or I mean you name the guy wrong yeah I
mean Aaron Roger said he gave somebody a
salary at Ryan Brown was cheating and
even your friends you know yeah I'll
just say this in support of Sean Noah
that what we all want to believe that
every college basketball coach is dirty
I think fans want to believe every
college basketball coach is dirty I
don't you know we want to believe that
every politician is dirty I don't
there's people don't want to believe
that every every pastor every preacher
is skimming off the top for their own
for their own betterment I I don't I
believe there are good I believe in good
people and the Christian dawkins is a
guy who was fired from the agency a
Miller's agency because he ran up a
$40,000 uber bill and put it up card you
know NBA players card so nothing's at
this point before the indictment of his
assistant coach would lead you to
believe they're doing things the wrong
way the Arizona so I want to believe him
the problem is that there was some
legalese that was put in there right
where he said I've never knowingly you
know acquitted a violation and and I do
feel like there was a lot of I there
which was speech to think that if
anybody's gonna get thrown under the bus
it's book Richardson who's already
indicted and already off the staff yeah
I'm trying to think you know if that
comes out because ESPN doubled down on
this as well so Sean Miller doubled down
so somebody is not telling the truth or
somebody correct maybe their semantics
involved in this but I'm guessing
somebody's gonna be able to listen to
that FBI wiretap and go is that Sean
Miller yes no and then then we have our
next chapter with this but I don't know
what I think the question DP the
question I guess maybe I'll ask to you
is all right let's say that it was about
a different player there was money
mentioned but he didn't there was no
money ever delivered and he passed on
the idea of paying for a player so ESPN
gets the gist of the story right but
gets the player actually wrong what what
then do we do is it Sean Miller on that
tape though that
that's where I want to start and I think
we do have the wrong player in there I I
think that that is a distinct
possibility that it could be Sean Miller
there could be a discussion but it's not
DeAndre Aten it's another player see I
had been told that it was a different
all along all season long people have
wondered what's going on in Arizona and
what you know and like look this is no
exact science I would never go to print
with it but the Running Room ER in
college basketball was that it was
another Arizona assistant and it wasn't
you know it was there was you're
passionate because now the UCSB head
coach that was that was what everyone
had said boy kill passionate I heard
he's on the tape right but there was all
kinds of rumors so we don't know and I
guess the question becomes did yes she
ended the SPN go to print essentially
with a rumor with you know or with the
with hearsay evidence from you know the
attorney representing Christian Dawkins
and not with not with facts or not with
multiple sources I think I think there's
there's we kind of therein lies the rub
can we play another clip from Sean
Miller where he does address the payment
to a player I also want you to know that
the one time that someone suggested to
me paying a player to come to the
University of Arizona I did not agree to
it it never happened and that player did
not come to the University of Arizona if
you're Sean Miller do su know I mean
here's the problem with suing is now
suddenly you know how you get cost
examined and every every recruiting
tactic ever you know comes into question
so I don't think it's a really high bar
that you have to you have to prove
malice at two in order to sue and you
know now sudden everything get you get
full disclosure on your entire coaching
career and I don't think anybody really
wants that so this is like Peyton
Manning who threatened to sue over that
al-jazeera thing like it sounds like a
great idea to jump back and sue the one
thing and this would be counter to I
know that Sean had a process to which he
had to speak to his bosses and answer
questions whatever but it did take until
Thursday till we got a response somebody
says hey G paid DeAndre
my response to be no I never paid the
Andre you know I wasn't like what why if
the truth is what ultimately will set
you free why would you ever you know
Hato high but not not have a press
conference not answer questions
immediately after this story broke he's
had plenty of opportunities to do so
again I want to believe Shawn and I
haven't you know people haven't been
whispering about Arizona running a dirty
program for years that's not what this
is you know it was it was surprising but
there are some holes there to which you
start scratching your head going okay
well maybe yes being screwed up some of
the names in the story but did they get
the gist of it right because otherwise
why would ESPN be doubling down one
night no no no no Texas Hold'em hey Doug
thank you have a good weekend we
appreciate you joining us thank you Dan
that's a Doug Gottlieb Fox sport for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]